[Music]
do any of you guys listen to Taylor
Swift's music all the time
own acts like not on purpose this she's
that popular she's everywhere
like that once on the stick it off too
right I guess no all right so whatever
Swift has recently lashed out against
the President and I see that she's
spanning you she is and she kind of has
never really gotten to the Paulette
politics as a celebrity and recently
she's regretted not been more active and
with everything that's happening right
now in our nation she's decided to lash
out and quote after stoking the fires
the white supremacy and racism your
entire presidency you have the nerve to
feign moral superiority before
threatening violence when the looting
starts the shooting starts question mark
was remark was in my commercial Mike so
Trump is in some hot water for that
particular phrasing when they're
shootings when the looting starts the
shootings and he's telling all the
protesters thugs thugs yes yes and so
you need someone to write as tweets firm
or like or figure out a better way to
get messages out yes Twitter even took
that [ __ ] down to true for me like I've
tried to give Trump like you know like
the benefit of the doubt that he'll do
some right things here in there oh man
he does so [ __ ] that's like oh my god
dearly by calling it China virus
[ __ ] well I mean okay hi hi from
a comedians mind yes it's funny but yeah
like he's our nation's leader he has so
much influence over so many people that
are very ignorant so now they the
ignorant ones that our races are like
exactly now I can be racist because he's
just valid dammit our messiahs Hey
true excuse to act a one so like [ __ ]
like that it's like Karen break out the
mess we're going on a protest I don't
already broke out the man down [ __ ] this
[ __ ] like that like he doesn't realize
the weight that his words carry he's not
just a regular man amongst men you know
yes [ __ ] although like you know that
the tension and the racism that does go
down they're always screaming true
they're like hey [ __ ] get out of here
whatever it need if they're caught on
video at the end they go draw that's why
we elected true yeah and I'm like damn
dude that's crazy dude yeah he doesn't
realize what he's doing they're being
weaponized there's another tweet that he
did so they're doing a comparison right
where I think it was Michigan or
something else where there was a protest
and he was condemning the the mayor or
the governor of a certain area yeah that
it was many minutes no but it was it was
during that time it was a bunch of it
was more like white protesters and in so
he was saying inaudible no no no we're
he called the mayor week right yeah he
called the mayor wrong and he's like
well like like ease it up or they he
couldn't handle it and then there is
basically a comparison of how he reacts
based off of you know the - yeah yeah
yeah and it wasn't yeah it was it was
not fair but yeah for all the terrible
things he said sometime he says some
pretty pretty [ __ ] funny [ __ ] though
I when he when he responded to Taylor
Swift he goes I like Taylor's music
about 25% less now 25% is likely 25% I'm
like [ __ ] dude [ __ ] troll man
sometimes I wished I wasn't a comedian
so that I can like not half of it I'm
like laughing and then the other half
like I wish I could just take the
message and be like oh man and I like
hate him as much as everyone else
because one part of me I'm like this
guy's pretty funny I'm in disbelief is
more my the lap is more like shock and
disbelief it's not like I support it
yeah
what it is for you - what what he just
said laughing disbelief oh yeah yeah
yeah but the president is saying crazy
[ __ ] president yeah I mean when you are
the president there it comes like a
certain amount of responsibility and you
cut you I do think you have to conduct
yourself a certain way you know I wish I
thought like you guys do I really do but
I never looked at the president when
that's who I want to be if anything
that's what he was there for right he's
supposed to be the leader he's supposed
to be with you it's cute it's all cute
it is very cute it's so cute but but at
the end of the day look there they're
all just a front for the same [ __ ]
war economy so I don't really I don't
see it the same way uh-huh
so yeah they're all in cahoots with each
other okay there's common knowledge and
there's things that most people believe
which is the system and what our
politicians are supposed to represent
that they actually believe in the things
that they say and all that but then
beyond that I feel like there's a group
of us who are starting to see the facade
so that's why I'm like it doesn't really
matter who's in office because they say
one thing but the policies and all those
things that they actually put into play
does it really help well we all yell
about never helps anybody all right
you notice we never yell about needing
health care we do for a little bit but
then everyone's just like oh no we got
to [ __ ] take down Trump we gotta
[ __ ] take down Obama Oh Benghazi Oh
Russia gate all or Obama gate or
whatever we'll never really talk about
the things that people actually need
that will help them like instead let's
focus on the nine you shove like what
somebody just said right now instead of
focusing on the things that Americans
actually need so that's why I'm very
cynical about it that's all very true
very true yeah and then the reforms
start rolling this take - I just
realized there's a side article here on
the web page that's opened up right now
and says George Floyd and Derek Chauvin
once worked overlapping stickety shifts
at the same nightclub and that [ __ ]
blew my mind and the bar goes yeah they
knew each other for 17 years yeah oh
yeah so apparently they've known each
other for a while and
I guess have history with each other so
that part's pretty crazy because it's
not like he it's like he had his night
knee on someone then there's just
footage that was released of then having
Floyd in the backseat of their patrol
SUV and they're beating the [ __ ] out of
them there's that - yeah footage yeah
was it this time or another time I mean
the same asian cop is watching so I'm
assuming this is unless it's they're
like a gang and they travel together
that time well they're partners I think
yes so then it's possible incidents
against them them as a part as a group
look so there's footage of them beating
them in the backseat and insult so
they're outside so they somehow got from
back seat to outside is a separate
incident oh yeah I think too much into
it I just saw the video
hey okay so they known each other for 17
years how do we know who now this just
sounds like they work like the same
shift right happy worked security at El
Nuevo rodeo Club el nuevo was that a
strip club
maybe I don't it doesn't say you didn't
save it's a strip club or not and I
think a body cam footage also show from
one of the cops that one of the cops
took the pulse of George Floyd and after
he said he I can't feel a pulse
David Shaw vans name was still on him
for extra two minutes after this is like
[ __ ] personal watch the video watch
the video from 2019 where the cops
they do the same thing to a guy who was
on the ground they choke him out same
[ __ ] that put a knee on his neck
everything I made these they're laughing
the whole time they're making fun of him
it's on CBS you can I don't know what
the guy's name was he's some white guy
but he got the same exact [ __ ] happen to
him and they're actually making fun of
him the whole [ __ ] time even after
he's basically expired
that is there's like a list going on
right now - of like 40-something people
that died in the hands of police within
the last just even two years uh you know
like a mod and you know who was the
other guy in New York that was selling
sex cigarettes friend ray yeah Freddie
gray I can't breathe uh guy and all that
just a list
and it and it has it's not even like
they're charged with the crime there's
just a list of possible what happened
and it's like George Floyd was for jury
right
and it's like sailing SEC like
cigarettes and it's like possible
they're not even it's not even like a
like a critical level threat I'm in the
felony not even a felony how about that
no cuz he's harassing people the thing
is like at least for police right when
you get a dispatch and it's like armed
and dangerous possible robbery all these
things then they approach the situation
with that level of force it's like being
swatted right you come in and they're
coming in guns running but if a
dispatcher is calling you in for more of
like a white collar car forgery forgery
gun ready to kill you right how does it
my question is how does it end here like
I need to still see it cuz I I haven't
really when I say this I want to go down
the investigation hole of like what's
wrong with our system where it always
ends up in this crazy disaster well they
always say they resist arrest
that they're being aggressive do do it
this one video where a lady was standing
there and a cop just punches her in the
face and he's like stop resisting arrest
I've seen that video do you feel like
you have immunity like that and you can
get away with that and nobody's gonna
touch you then yeah you you're
invincible cuz you're unleashing bullies
you're unleashing crazy people into the
public so that's whose fault is that our
CD and our [ __ ] authorities I
followed this a SWAT guy he works in one
of the California apartments and he had
a post and I really liked because he was
saying like pretty much he was saying
like he was condemning all these cops
are acting out online and he was like
saying you guys have to remember we are
peace officers we uphold the peace we
serve and protect and he goes no way in
and you know when you think about that
you're like what kind of peace were they
upholding or even the way that like they
respond to rioters it's not so they're
not allowed to like you punched the cop
and they punch you back that's also not
upholding peace
you know it's it's technically like
almost like a god it should be like a
Gandhi like approach where you only use
violence to de-escalate because you
perforce in that corner but if he's here
for forgery like who are you protecting
them from with the knee on his neck yeah
and what kind of piece are you upholding
with the knee on the neck it's just it's
just crazy I'm knowing the fact that
they used to like work together I feel
like it's now like a personal like no
right because like I think like when I
was watching the video and like the
people are like get off his neck he
can't breathe right like I the cop it
deliberately just like dug his knee in
onto his neck as they're saying get off
get off and like you could just see like
I don't know to me the way that I read
his body posture was like [ __ ] you I'm
[ __ ] doing this because like you know
what cuz I can like that's that's how it
read to me cuz like just him just
putting his [ __ ] me in there I like
what the [ __ ] dude let go home and when
they pull them off the floor he looked
dead already
yeah pronounced dead later I'm like I
don't know man it's got less lifeless
like Nepal this is the [ __ ] that
they did with Freddie gray though is
like they say that like this this
incident oh it's so tragic because it
unleashed a chain of events that led to
his death because he had cardiac arrest
all the stuff as a result of of what
they did to him but man he was just
someone cigarettes on a street corner so
like like if they if he hadn't been
stopped or whatever the [ __ ] they all
had to tackle on nine people on top of
him he would have just been so and say
curse in the street corner not chain
reaction [ __ ] but that's that's
unfortunately the problem with the
justice system right is you have to be
able to prove like to a grand jury
beyond a reasonable doubt that these
cops intended to kill this person and
that's how they were able to slide so
there's a problem in the system
fundamentally right so the he he's now
apprehended in Florida and then he's
being charged for a third degree murder
but there's three other cops who were
nothing's happening to them as as
assistants or nothing like that yeah I
mean this is literally what happened
with Rodney King right clearly those
guys were repeatedly beating him with
clubs caught on videotape right and all
of them chill nothing happened to them
and if not for the videotape nobody
would even know
if not for the videotape I mean in the
90s and LAPD was known to plant drugs on
just random citizens and also training
people up picking them up in the car
dropping them off in different gang
neighborhoods beating them up
it was crazy horizons justice scandals
we know about man - back then they
didn't have video like like now in that
Rodney King the video was actually
recorded by a white dude a neighbor that
had a camcorder and he was recording
this whole thing right so thank God for
him yeah and and but that's the thing
though the city burned down because the
city basically failed us and and and
they let all the cops go and it's the
same thing that's happening right now
and I don't know if it's gonna continue
on because now we have the power of
recording [ __ ] and everyone's seeing the
facade everyone's seeing the corruption
I think things are gonna change I hope
so - yeah you know it feels like it's
about the we're gonna see some changes
coming this doesn't change with police
training then we're just back to square
one yep honest to god like for the
record the the the manager of that club
said that she wouldn't characterize
Chauvin and floyd being like friends
like knowing each other like that but
they definitely worked on the same team
and definitely have crossed paths so
it's not a complete stranger is what it
is a complete stranger so if you
recognize them and on top of that if
there's footage of him beating him
there's some tension or something there
that's personal but the fact that the
partner didn't do [ __ ] and the other
adds there's a problem inside of
policing right now or they don't feel
like it's safe to rat out other cops
yeah and that has to change or we're all
just gonna stand by the way there is a
list of whistleblowers that you guys can
check out many from the police
department have came out there's
documentaries all that and I feel like
as a society we need to listen and back
them up when it's not the time that's
convenient such as now since everyone's
talking about it now people are like
we're all the cops that are doing it
they been whistleblowing dude off the
chain bro that's the helm it doesn't go
up the chain doesn't actually get
[ __ ] like investigated and checked
out in fact the people at the higher up
levels they actually excuse a lot of it
and
there's multiple documentaries about the
blue veil yeah there's one NYPD one that
came out like four years ago but you're
right it doesn't get anywhere so that's
why people feel I think even at least
they feel helpless they're like you know
what I'm just gonna get do my job get my
paycheck I came here to actually change
the world but I'm getting stamped down
by my own department I need my pension
yep
whatever I could do to protect that if
we were ever to threaten that by the way
you have actual results but they retired
by yes they do they work for it
[Music]